le 16 avril dernier c'est le naufrage
d'une embarcation de pêche au niveau des
côtes du prêcheur nécessitant
l'intervention de la vedette de la snsm
qui permet de démanteler un réseau
exploitant la misère humaine 21e' siens
dont cinq mineurs et de dominique est
tous en situation irrégulière sont
interpellés ce dossier de castillo
prenant est confiée à un magistrat de la
juridiction interrégionale spécialisée
une procédure a été ouverte par la jirs
ce de fort de france et a permis dans un
premier temps donc l'interpellation de
deux individus qui se trouvent être les
individus qui avaient permis à ces
personnes de prendre ainsi la mer dans
des conditions extrêmement dangereuses
et ces deux individus là ont été placés
en garde à vue et ont été ensuite placé
en détention provisoire
contre toute attente la perquisition
menée sur le terrain permet de découvrir
un surprenant regroupement de femmes
d'origine haïtienne chez un particulier
à cette marée dans le nord atlantique la
martinique
dans le cas de ce dossier donc une
perquisition récente dans un domicile à
sainte-marie a permis de découvrir
quinze personnes 15 femmes qui se
trouverait également en situation
irrégulière et qui se trouvait de tout
évidence ici de manière transitoire
avant d'être sans doute dispatchés dans
ailleurs en martinique un trafic qui ne
surprend nullement les prix chopin du
nord caraïbes
il déclare que régulièrement qu'ils
assistent à des débarquements dans ce
secteur
voyez ici à compenser
à béjaïa
contre la console de sony sera fait ces
anciens nantais dominique est vraiment
difficile à rabat comme il nous l'a
demandé il aura été la pasta et au parti
ababou l'animé reprenant tel mouvement
c'est la nouvellement gouvernement
dominicain a fait l'arrêt mais si toi
récit national que vous frappez pas ce
que j'allais passer va pas aussi mal de
semaines passées à la même là ces
médicaments étaient pouvoir y lancer aux
couleurs at-elle toupet à la bourgogne
selon nos sources ces femmes qui fuient
la misère d'haïti serait destiné ce
droit à des hommes contre rénumération
ou encore exploité dans l'agriculture
pour l'heure sept personnes de 28 à 68
ans sont mises en examen pour trafic en
bande organisée traite d'êtres humains
et association de malfaiteurs
elles sont placées en détention
provisoire